new in theaters this weekend the
possession of a Hannah grace this is
your weekend ticket
buckle up do you have a possession
obsession well I have a confession
this weekend the possession of Hannah
grace Grace's our presents make sure to
get your concessions because if you
don't have your concessions in your
possession you might not get permission
for admission unless we make a
concession too much sorry I have a
passion for my profession I just blacked
out what just happened the possession of
Hannah grace comes out this weekend
former cop now newest nightshift morgue
worker Megan read is tasked with
processing the body of Hannah Grace who
is killed during an exorcism
if an exorcism isn't completed evil will
find a new vessel
I believe when you know you died in this
story then you're up for it I could
handle it totally normal what could go
wrong everything everything could go
wrong
this movies for you if you like horror
movies you're glad November is almost
over but you're still holding on to that
October vibe before we hit December or
your possession obsession is like a
remix to ignition
you know hot and fresh out the kitchen
that is your weekend ticket what will
you see check back next week to see
Margot Robbie and Saoirse Ronan team up
and Mary Queen of Scots
[Music]